on va mettre ce qu'on appelle des bois
dressés 7 ce qui est assez en la passe
qui permet d'équilibrer le bateau on va
les placer je vais vous expliquer
comment monter dessus puisque cette fois
vous allez faire aujourd'hui
voici un équipage féminin habitué à
concourir en bb yole alors quoi de plus
naturel pour elle que d'accueillir un
autre groupe de filles les candidates de
miss martin venus s'initier ce matin une
miss
cette fine ambassadrice du patrimoine de
sa région alors laguiole est un monde à
découvrir
même s'il faut pour cela mettre de côté
quelques appréhensions
c'est un peu nerveuse mais c'est
j'avance normal c'est la première fois
qu'on fait cette activité mais je suis
super excité j'avais hâte à ce jour donc
que du bonheur surtout de l'excitation
l'appréhension pourrait gâcher la chose
je vends ce gel en fait d'appréhension
alors attention aux bleus attention au
but à tout à l'heure
les techniques de base seront expliquées
avant le départ par exemple comment
positionner les bois dressés de façon à
ne pas gêner la manoeuvre ni blesser un
coéquipier
les filles partiront en compagnie de
laguiole de laurent mas un tout nouvel
équipage paraît pour rejoindre le
championnat des grandes gueules cette
année elles vont vraiment équilibré les
bateaux ça c'est sûr donc qu'il reste
conçu des mois d'essai après diriger le
bateau ça sera ça sera un des jeunes
femmes at-il ou des jeunes qui ont envie
d'apprendre
[Musique]
pour une première les miss compte une
mère parfaitement qu'elle invente léman
est une toute petite voile de 30 mètres
carrés et c'est bien assez pour
découvrir les premières sensations
moi comme j'ai comme j'ai eu peur donc
ça a été un peu la panique pour moi mais
au final ça a été assez soutenue les
unes et des autres et donc ça s'est
super bien passé et au final ça a été
une belle expérience trop notre super
une expérience fantastique
c'est la première fois que je fais du de
laguiole et c'était franchement génial
c'est physique très physique et il faut
dresser il faut sentir le bateau il faut
sentir la mer après le concours de miss
martinique le 4 octobre prochain
l'association vini ouais ça aura
peut-être de nouvelles recrues
[Musique]